you never and I mean never
leave someone who is drunk alone without a way to get home
I was leaving the library at 5:00am and this girl
I hear her come into the library just as my Uber is pulling up
and she's asking security guard if he had a charger because her phone was dead
and I'm like what's going on
and as I'm walking out
like the security guard is being useless
and so I give her my portable charger and this girl is p!ssed drnk
like it is 5:00am
she's like in boots
she has she's not aware of what's going on
and like I'm trying to help her like
figure out where she needs to go for her phone is dead
it's charging on my thing
eventually I just like
I have to type her address into my phone and call her Uber myself
because I don't know who she was with or what her friends were doing
but I cannot comprehend how you go out with someone who
I'm assuming you call your friend
and then leave them in New York City alone p!ss drnk
especially right now when people are getting punched in the face
what is wrong with you
I don't care what the situation
there is no reason why you should be letting your friend who is like
so drnk that they can't function
walk home alone
especially if they're girl and especially if their phone is dead
anyone that does it to you is not your friend
and y'all need to be better friends
I’m like so mad right now